and the royals have a two-out rally
working with cordero coming up mills to
franchi curveball hit on the ground
right to the first baseman rizzo grabs
it touches first base and that does it
for kc
bryant leading off the game tonight with
a double but he is still at second with
two outs
a breaking ball and he went around so
duffy works around the double royals
have two on the second straight inning
to start the night it will bring up
brett phillips he swings away out into
shallow left bias with a long run and he
makes it look easy
that's out number two
now back to the top and mary field
fly ball half out in right center
it's going to be hayward though as a
wind
made it his play
the royals have stranded royals have
left four base runners in the first two
winnings batter is alex gordon
this is bodhi and he got him what a play
david bodie
in the shift basically playing shortstop
gets alex gordon they continue to flash
the leather body the third baseman
playing way over in the straight up
shortstop position with a sweetheart of
a play well that was a gorgeous play how
about this the arm strength right there
by bode as well that's a beautiful play
phillips stands well off the plate
runner goes pitches outside
ow
boy bias does such a great job of
letting that ball come in deep instead
of going out and grabbing it
he's over two
that's hit hard but right to bias who
gets maryfield bias catches it on the
line it's three and two alec mills on a
payoff
he got him
looking
for his third strikeout bases loaded
here comes rizzo big spot in this game
and he got a pop-up
they call the infield fly rule as monday
makes the play that's a big out for
duffy here's baez duffy's 1-1 pitch
hit in the air right field the catch is
made by francie cordero runner tags
throw home is not in time
chicago takes the early one-nothing lead
that's all the damage that's done this
inning this will be a good inning for
duffy to see if we find a way to get out
of it
that slider is pulled on the ground to
franco
and that is in the dirt ryan o'hearn
bails him out chicago settles for one
mill still working here in the seventh
this one hit pretty well slicing and
it'll be hayward to make the grab man to
that ball
dip to the right
that was hit right at half off the bat
it's got some sliced spin and then i
pushed it even further and you could
tell it was kind of a funky free for
jason it's out number one the batter now
alex gordon
bounce back to the mound should be an
easy play that's out number two well an
excellent job by mills so far
and he's going to try to bun his way on
and david body gets him oh what a play
by bodhi he's had a great night with the
glove and the arm here is chris bryant
bryant with a double and a walk from the
stretch
bryant drives one left center field
pretty well hit back coast gordon and
phillips near the wall gone
home run chris bryant
into left center his first of the year
somehow he got it out of here
into the stiff wind he does not wait he
jumps on that first offering from ian
kennedy for home run number one pitcher
for kansas city right-hander josh
starment yeah they like this kid he can
light up the radar gun
manti and man bun
called strike three to get javi that was
probably line of the night right there
well jd set me up
here's contreras
here comes another one
goodness gracious
analyze come on guys give us something
here yeah while we
all just shaking our heads
goodness gracious and wow so far and
that's pretty much
describes what this kid is doing
wow
yep
what an inning for stamen two nothing
ninth inning quick trying to save it for
alec mills
this should do it
wind blowing javi camps under it cubs
win
cubs win again
they shut out the royals tonight
two nothing on five hits they're eight
and two
and the string of starting pitching
continues just unbelievable the run
they've been on seven scoreless for
malik mills here tonight that's a career
high those seven innings pitch well
played game gracie
it sure was